move
i have joints at home i forgot to bring
him i think it's better with uh
marijuana and stuff
it's podcasting
everything is better with marijuana
wow
well i know gingers are more sensitive
to pain
so
wow
you can withstand more huh the sun
especially
really it's a raw nerve that's that's a
bad deal
does that work with emotional pain too
yeah
yeah i can tell
really yeah damn well william's very
sensitive in a good way
[Laughter]
look he's hurt he's so sensitive right
now
is my face close enough
yeah that's kind of in the dark a little
bit you know i don't know why it's so
dark
because the light is far away from us
no this is
the light in the uh
in the hallway maybe yeah
that's a little bit better i think the
camera is just that weird
that's that's what the vomit is
[Music]
oh yeah we're here live at the vulcan
green room where there's vomit in the
sink right now my favorite thing is i
saw that bathroom was one time um just
during a show the leaf the
roof started leaking and it was just a
constant stream of water
well thank you vulcan for letting us
film here
what is your horror story here about
this
where they got that rain water you're
drinking
that rain water is good that's like i
don't know
it's so funny they made it sparkling
you're the opposite of a cloud
yeah i mean normally i have to when i'm
pounding those things but last night i
didn't be
and then when i did it was bro maybe
you're saving it up for a big swarm
hey go to the doctor like now
now you know how clouds feel when
they're like gray they're like
awesome
you know is that how a cloud layout
would talk
do the clouds are aggressive
maybe when they have to pee yeah no okay
they're not that's fair so when they
have to be then they rain
yeah the rain comes red exactly
and when they come it's lightning
when they come it's lightning yeah wow
and while they come into austin all the
time i'll tell you that right now yeah
god there was a bad storm like a couple
wednesdays ago and i didn't make it back
to my apartment and i was ended up
having to pull over because it started
hailing underneath like this metal thing
this metal roof and everything was
shaking and i was like oh my god
i'm about to die in a tornado or
something right the car was moving
around oh my gosh i'd give me this yeah
are you scared of thunderstorms
or have you yeah
yeah
growing up in memphis after hurricane
elvis yeah hurricane elvis hurricane
elvis it was like in 2008 or something
it's a bad storm in the summertime damn
100 mile an hour winds my mom woke us
all all up screaming
and i woke up and it was windy kind of
inside the house which had never
happened it was windy out it's kind of
windy inside of the house
wait what's going on
yes it has strong winds happening
so you saw a lot of tornadoes and stuff
it's a lot of tornado sirens
uh that's almost worse than a tornado
like it's [ __ ] so fun this is so
funny watching hans just move everything
around
this has been what are you thinking that
was my face not sitting here was it that
close enough or something move this way
move towards me
someone said i look like william's son
thanks dad
and then you gotta readjust yourself
um yeah i mean i'm already really white
so maybe we should have the white people
on in the dark side
i don't know i was already oh wait no
that's good now yeah they got there they
got me
what the hell are you talking about
so we're watching him just we can see
ourselves get set up in this camera
right now this is really fun
how do you know how to do all that on i
don't everyone's complaining about the
audio
oh are they everybody complains with red
band
all his audio i think all the time
what are they saying
people just they're saying they really
like everyone here
and they they love god and they think
he's good
i really love everyone here
yeah
i love you guys
do you really mean that yeah i do i
seriously
i love everyone that's the scary thing
about riley
is that he really does love everyone
it's kind of a problem it's like not a
good thing
how many people do you love right now
because then you talk to homeless people
a billion trillion yeah but then like
i mean i can also love everyone and not
and like really like not want to be
around them if they're not cool like a
like that homeless guy so like people
who even the people who wrong you in
some way you love
yeah i mean i think forgiveness is key
to uh a better
life you heard it here first folks well
you heard it
you heard it here for another time wait
hans so you mentioned the homeless
person earlier
talking to homeless people
you have to be careful i know but
yeah i know be careful
yeah what if it's somebody having a bad
day what if he bites me and then i
become homeless
is that how it works
yeah that's how it works
you don't know who you're talking
you don't know if someone you're talking
to someone who's completely not here if
there was someone watching you guys talk
it would look like two homeless people
talking yeah yeah you had like a stain
on your shirt
your glasses yeah yeah i see that dark
stain
there was more prominent oh it's a
shadow
there's one prominent earlier you
definitely you drank something like
purple or red oh it was my heart beating
yeah we can see through translucence
he was just like trying to explain how
like i should give him money
um and how he's like not gonna buy drugs
but he was like so high that he i
couldn't comprehend what he was saying
but you stuck around to listen well i
was just like i gotta go man
because the message he was it was kind
of a sweet message he was like you know
why wouldn't you give money like
but i was like because you're high
i gave my water i gave my water that's
probably better actually yeah yeah i
don't i don't mind giving something like
physical like food or water like i'll
give that all the time would you be more
inclined to give someone money if
they're honest if they're like i'm gonna
use this for drugs
um it depends what kind of drugs
what do you mean it depends
like if it's like zyrtec maybe i don't
know or like yeah
i know that's zortec is on a list of
homeless people wanted drug
i don't think homeless people are
worried about their allergies i'd find a
really filled prescription
yeah they're like
[ __ ] man anyone have any dayquil yeah
but if they were like i'm gonna use this
for heroin would you be more inclined to
give it to them no honest no
if it was for weed i might i might do it
i'll give homeless people weed i have
like weed
i think wheat is fine we took it well
it's like compared to heroin yeah it's
like league's better that's right yeah
but i don't want like to give like an
addictive drug
william what would drug would you give
them maybe
um
vitamin c
some tang
did you ever have tank growing up no
it's an orange dress dude i love tang
with the orangutan
and did you all see that video today i
saw a video today as some guy who's a
little too close to the orangutan
enclosure the gravity orangutan perhaps
ass
shirt and then he slowly works his way
up and then other people try to help him
and then the recognition i'm gonna grab
you [ __ ] you better back up and he just
keeps grabbing on the shirt until he
works his way to his leg as soon as he's
holding on to his leg with his hand and
his feet the three and it looks like
three of the same thing he looks like he
has three hands on his legs
and then seeing the guys sideways
and the dude the orangutan is just
holding on to him so tight
is good what did he let go did the guy
get away yeah no they never there's no
end there's no end to it oh it's just
them struggling it's open-ended
i wonder if it ends up killing him it
seems like those things are so strong
i think eventually right someone with
some kind of blow dart would be like go
to sleep
damn
we have the same color here
orangutans
it looked like a dude he's like yeah
come here you could see him talking to
me like
i know he's dead and then he gets his
shirt and he's real quick
it must have been a homeless orangutan
honestly don't you think we deserve it
for all we do to orangutans like if we
had video of what we do to orangutan
what do you think tang is made out of
it yeah industry secret
yeah
also aids
but
yeah what the hell are you talking about
what's your roommate talking about
all right you guys can drive the
conversation i'm just trying to how is
it living with each other we don't wish
to we didn't don't anymore
i live with a bunch of door guys from
the creek okay
do they are they
do they have a lot of doors in the house
they're gonna like let you in
of course they're like
sorry bathroom's closed
yeah i uh room's closed does have a door
yeah yeah bathroom's closed for cleaning
i feel better now
i broke the i broke the base of the
creek bear recently
oh [ __ ] yeah i took i was
so i did this last weekend
this is this past weekend and i got to
see like stephen randolph like just a
friend i haven't seen in forever right
now
afterwards let's take a pic on the bear
right and then i climbed up on the bear
because i was like oh you can totally
climb up on the bear and you can't and i
the little ice is on a little pond like
the thing and i fell through that fell
through the ice oh my god okay
damn and yeah yeah wait
it's so distracting on stage you think
so the bear yeah i like the bear i'm a
big bear fan
yeah i like the bear too what other
stage has a bear on it i know it's
really fun
isn't it like you have to address it no
you don't i i've never what people do i
wonder if a lot of people do address
them they know almost nobody addresses
the bear
yeah cause it's part of the stage but
it's so that's why shane gilles do it
distracting well yeah well on that on a
special you might have to address the
bear for sure yeah yeah yeah it's not
special but no i
most people don't address the bear it's
just part of the stage it would be like
addressing the stool
i gotta address the stool yeah
yeah that's why i like the bear it's not
like oh everyone's thinking about it
i learned so many shows there where the
bears never mentioned
that's why i like it it's it's
legitimately like a part of the stage it
can become a prop but you can't
you can't step on it so this is fragile
the bear is fragile isn't it like
covering up like wires or something
no i don't think so because for the so
uh where did you hear that this last
video this last weekend was uh
this last weekend
this last week it was a special taping
the bear was off stage and there was it
was a stage
oh wow yes this was stated were they
working on the thing that you broke did
they have to take it somewhere no no
they just they didn't want it on stage
for the special oh because they were
like it's well it's already been in one
like pretty special
a special amount of time yeah yeah
special it was that traditional special
amount of time
it was like a full out it wasn't one of
those like 20 minute specials that like
people are just calling specials yeah
like [ __ ] whoever does like that one
comment
[Music]
right i don't want you to homeless
people your brain is polluted with the
filth of the streets what
you gotta stop hanging out on the
streets does he really honest does he
really just hang out on the streets
that's where i got these flip-flops
[ __ ] wait people are buying first
oh i know i made them out of
star trek
no
i saw him i was like struggling with all
this mic equipment and seeing riley like
distracted talking to a homeless person
well he was talking to me you don't
understand i didn't know that i was
trying to go
to the homeless person yeah you don't
engage no i he was walking with me like
i was just like okay um well
at some point you engaged
you're right
there's no they don't just start at home
walking next to people at some point you
engaged yeah well i i wanted to hear him
out
a little bit because i do i mean i hang
out there i do feel sorry i'm like you
know he is homeless right like
don't feel sorry for him that's the last
thing he would want why not
that's the last thing he would want
he wants you to respect him
yeah come on
but i don't know i mean uh i don't
i just i like talking to people who live
on like a different side of
reality
yeah you live on a different side of
town than me so
you're like a downtown it's great to
talk to homeless people but they want
something for me they're not just having
a conversation in good faith they're
like trying to trick you so that they
can take as much from you as possible as
they have to at a best practice
at least the ones yeah i know and
especially the ones downtown the
downtown that's not homeless or like
kind of dangerous yeah no one time right
at least they were just almost
personally pretending to be like a
parking attendant and she was like yeah
like that you have to pay you like the
thing is broken you have to give me five
dollars and then i'll call it
right right that's that's that's a uh
that's a skit that's a scam that one of
them that one of them
you know what's funny if if they do that
because it's like usually like it's in
the free if it's in the free lot they'll
be like i'm gonna get five dollars yeah
i'll give it to him because it's like
initiative it's like
i'll pay you a little bit more
you know and then i just tell them to
make sure to watch my car and be late
yeah there was this one guy who was like
pointing to like the space and i already
saw the space
and he's like he was just like i was
like already driving into the space
and he was like and then he like started
pointing you almost after like i started
going and he's like oh i get five
dollars oh yeah man you're welcome for
the space
i'm like
or well really couldn't have done it
without you yeah well i never go to a
space that someone points to i know
why do you want me to why are you so
interested in where i park yeah
yeah you're gonna need your most
valuable possession there yeah
knows where it is
or
where they want me to park
sorry for pointing at you i feel like
that was rude that was kind of rude why
did you do that
people told me not to point at them yeah
you're kind of far away
oh i was like talking about the space
but i was
like we're shooting a guy
look at you
gosh this is a post evolving society
that's helped you moldy society
um
but yeah
uh
and then like i ended up just going and
looking at the machine
from like the homeless person i was like
oh it's not broken she's like oh well
yeah i mean it actually is
like
it was just like so easy to solve all
right i'm just gonna go look at the
machine and see if it's broken
wait i'm curious and this just walked
away you just said post-evolved society
do you think like anything's going to be
different from that
i think as like that's going to be a
marker between there was a preview of
all the time or post people i wish there
was but unfortunately not no right okay
i thought about that for a second i was
like i don't think that changes anything
yeah we're just gonna go on and we're
like oh oh damn it yeah yeah [ __ ]
anyways yeah until the next one what's
going on right yeah
like it happens when it starts happening
more people do it because the people
that are that [ __ ] up will do it for
attention right it's an essential people
getting attention
then they're more likely to do it well
that's why there was like three this
past weekend yeah yeah i don't think
that's a coincidence yeah yeah the one
orthopedic surgeon the poor guy he just
had back surgery
oh in tulsa yeah he just had back
surgery and he came back really soon
after with the gun
shot his ass and the other doctor and
some dude in there
and then himself
you know people are suffering yeah we
need to make people suffer less because
when humans suffer they're very good at
expressing it and it's horrible and
they're good in violent ways
so just keep them happy keep them fed
and then they won't do anything crazy
but if it's difficult
yeah dude someone just needs to [ __ ]
these kids like seriously like you
believe in that
i think that's almost just hey
is there is there
is there a correlation between the fact
that the catholic church got caught
[ __ ] kids and after that there's been
a rise in mass shootings maybe the
catholic church was doing as a service
[Applause]
they were you know doing that
they were the hero that we didn't know
we needed
yeah
someone's gotta [ __ ] these kids i was
gonna [ __ ] these kids
i think we should just get rid of
schools
what are you doing
a texas state senator
another driver children yeah really yeah
whoa
they only want they don't want the rich
to learn wow
like a field just put the kids in a
field where would the kids go if there
aren't any schools
they go to work that's what they're
working on put them in the factories
they got little fingers they would get a
textile for making clothes yeah
what for showing the little fingers
think about this right
we're having less and less kids
right so you got to replace the workout
how many kids do you have a son none
nine no i saw you with one the other day
yeah that's my like nephew
oh you have prolific
we have family we have a lot of family
yeah it's like i'm totally kidding okay
uh but no yeah like what
there's less people now there's less
people being made so you gotta replace
the workers somehow you gotta make the
kids work
into the past or
continue to say hey porque los dos why
not both kids
how hard is it to do this it seems like
we're doing this and it's not very well
done
it's like if they can do this [ __ ] up
left and right i'm sure robots can do
either way better or way worse
it's gonna be scary when and it pisses
me off the scientists who work on ai
stuff they're gonna be
they're gonna in the history books look
back at those people that made the ai
people so smart
well it kills me they're gonna be like
nazis in the future no well yeah and
in the future they're gonna be like
these were our creators because it's all
gonna be ai
it's just that they they got rid of the
pesky humans yeah it's pretty much you
know the evolution chart that goes from
ape to human yeah that just the next
one's gonna be an ai thing so that's how
they look at us they'll look at us like
the creators it'll look like the ai
thing in the will smith movie ai
yeah
they mean uh
yeah
i guess it was with haley joel osment
where he's a little kid and they make a
robot that you could love i thought that
was just something i think scientists
have already
put that out right the robot you can
love yeah
oh i don't know if it loves you back
wait i thought there was a sixth sense
no six sentences where haley joel
auspices dead people
oh
this is secretly dead the whole time
whoa spoiler whoa yeah oh my god
whoa i've been i've been seeing the
fourth or fifth sentence
touch i can touch them people
yeah i can taste them
i'll be able to smell them
what's the other one i always forget the
other one
touch i smell oh here we go
wait no there's is that four
there's another one how many sensors are
there six i think no there's five the
same sense
see
smell
feel oh that's that that's here let's
talk yeah here yeah what is it what's
the last one i don't know like touch and
feel maybe are different you can touch
something and then you feel it touch it
that's that's related
taste
yeah
wait so what is it no there's not feel
taste
touch
see
smell smell there it is
no you repeated one
you did that was fine
yeah
we kept like switching out the one that
wasn't there we just said all of them
it's touch taste
and then pause on your face
one two three touch the taste and things
on your face
that's how you can remember how about it
well the thing well taste is on your
face
[Applause]
hand and the rest are on your face
shoulders
but there's also proprioception which is
your body's ability to feel itself in
the air so when you're like running you
can feel your left hand is right here
and you're catching like feeling your
own how do you know about proprioception
i read it online overall yeah
wait what is it that's still an
extension of feel right yeah i guess
self-awareness is a real thing it's like
the four elements it's like not
scientific but it's like
it roughly approximates what we can do
what rock water fire
earth wind and fire
asia japanese i think that's metal too
that's like the fifth element i thought
metal was just an extension of earth
[Applause]
what the last airbender yeah
is that a good one universal
like dude real anime is just so violent
it's insane
like
it's so gross yeah it's like having
scandinavians like metal it's cause like
they're so calm and placid that they
need to like [ __ ]
go out and do crazy [ __ ] like
scandinavians are a little like death
metal because they're so bored
but probably real cold
yeah whatever you do up there they need
somewhere to get the energy out because
they're stored for all winters they just
scream
and
maybe hell will come to sweden and
[ __ ] warm it up for a second
you know what i mean like hell will come
because i'm trying to do it
a little bit
just for some warmth
that's my period how do people sing like
that it seems like they would hurt your
throat
[Music]
yeah how long can you do that
i feel like if i do it it'll change my
voice forever so i don't really want it
have you seen the north node
no
it's like about time
how is it was it good yeah it's so dark
and violent and boring it's just like
shows our sick society this is what we
look up to like the simplistic
animalistic
well that's how it was back in the day
i mean there's other parts that we can
focus on right i hear i hear richard but
we choose to focus on that because i
think that's what we're into
yeah it's about this guy who lives in
like a norse society and it's like
primitive it's like
proto-feudal
and this guy kills his dad
his brother kills his dad and then
the guy is like i'm gonna bench him and
it takes 30 years to avenge him and his
body yo don't give too many
don't give you're not going to give any
spoilers are you i was going to
[Applause]
i already know
[Music]
yeah just
like that sounds awful dude i don't know
if you have if you have a purpose it
makes life easier yeah as opposed to
like mcdonald's employees you see a
seven yeah yeah it's just like i was
meant to kill this man
i don't know i'm just kind of hanging
out figuring it out right what do you
mean about mcdonald's employees in
7-eleven i get what you can touch like
those absent-minded idiots that you talk
to
or they're just you just look at their
face and they're just gone
you know what i mean
yeah
i hear you
yeah and it's like oh god i'd rather i'd
rather be like i have to offend you man
i just have a personality yeah than to
be like i'm just here and then when i'm
just an npc in reality yeah what happens
when you're waiting to be activated
after 30 years
like you're just like [ __ ] man what do i
do now
if that's the choice
[Music]
yeah i only asked you earlier because i
go to 7-eleven a lot and i was like
what's he saying about 7 11.
i mean you were like
you read about it earlier the the answer
is comfort right if you give if you give
people who work at 7-eleven enough to
just like live
and go to the movies every once in a
while that's all it takes
but now it's like well i either work at
7-eleven for poverty wages
or i just [ __ ] go out with a bank
yeah and most people don't shoot up
schools which is amazing like
old enough then it doesn't work but if
you're young enough and you don't need
to suffer that much i mean maybe through
school
but school is just like a extension of
7-eleven
they're just getting ready getting you
ready for 7-eleven it's like the same
energy i went to school yeah
i haven't been to school in a while i
kind of liked school why would i
structure school i enjoyed school like
my buddies and stuff i would have fun
yeah it just seemed so much extra
nonsense as opposed to what actually was
well what else would you do i mean what
else are you gonna do just admit like
this is gonna be useless talk to each
other have fun you know don't make it
all about you know stuff that works test
scores and whatever yeah you're doing
useless worksheets
the teacher looks at it once throws it
away
for anyone
uh but well you would still have to
figure out how to
there's still basic things people need
to learn
you could probably figure that out
yeah like it doesn't seem like yeah
figure out figured out no the the goal
of it for a lot is just like a
babysitter yeah pretty much that like
that educates your kids but like the
education is also on the like the kids
have to still want to learn there's
nothing in the system that's like
to me that like oh this is we're we're
not we're just you know there's nothing
to help like kids want to learn that
seems like you either like the system or
you know yeah i mean riley had that bad
philosophy teacher now he's talking to
[ __ ] homeless people
that's like what are you talking about
as a philosophy teacher
dude you can learn philosophy from
homeless people man yeah they're
desperate they're actually living life
he was saying something to me that like
it's actually real it's just like why
wouldn't you give your money away to
someone who needs it like he's really
interested in the philosophy of giving
like he was like some people give like
this and other people give him like that
and it was just he was just like
breaking it down like yeah what he goes
through every day that's
we did the right thing we're like make
it short and quick you actually wasted
his day you could have been no i didn't
i i heard him out dude do you know how
like many people like pass by him and
like don't listen to him like you wasted
his time though maybe that could have
been far worse than just if he found
another target i don't think i'm wasting
how long did you talk a couple hours ago
you got a podcast yeah yeah
okay
i do understand like well he deserves a
shred of humanity there's none coming
his way all day yeah
i mean i'll talk to people out for sure
i'm better at it
i definitely will not talk about those
people but i still but i still
get that i'm just like most people think
like me so this guy does not get any
sort of
touch to touch base with the real world
at all and you're giving him that
yeah i get i get that and i'm still wild
i'm also genuinely interested in like
what people have to say
like on the other side of town
yeah come over to my side maybe you'll
get some money
do you think you'd be a good homeless
person um no for sure not
um yeah what what
constitutes a good homeless person yeah
i don't know i remember right when i
moved here it was raining outside and i
was stopped above a bridge and a
homeless guy comes up and i forgot my
windshield wipers were on because it was
on like the slow
when it only sporadically is moving
intermittent oh yeah and his ass comes
up with the squeegee and it [ __ ] hits
the squeegee and he makes some big deal
about it and falls backward i'm like
dude what the [ __ ] light turned green
what's even going on it was like he was
pulling trying to pull something like an
insurance scam but like
none of the faculty
actually do it they put me on ads i was
like turn green
can we get out of here
wow wait so you
why didn't you like it cause
because he just comes up
like he attacked him oh yesterday i was
driving my van and some lady was sitting
in on sixth street in the leftmost lane
just squatty squatting and then i drove
past her i was like bumping up and down
on the cobblestone in the intersection
and i got past her and she threw her
beard right in front of my car
oh really and then i drove home
like what i would think she would want
that yeah right i know i think she was
done with it
did she know it at you like in a
menacing kind of yeah
right in front of my car really yeah
it's like they're just playing with
danger and life and how much do you
really respect me and are you gonna run
me over or not like do i have am i worth
something to people
they just want that validation i think
would you have run her over no
the paperwork alone yeah
yeah it's like a thing yeah it's
definitely like a thing and then you
might have to go to therapy for it it's
like a lot it's like
yeah
and then the crush of the feeling it
under your car
hearing it and be like a melon
you think it would
like a melon dropping yeah depends if
you hit her and then her head hits the
back of the cement
that's i think where most of it would be
because my car's so big i have a van
i remember that video seeing that video
where you had to slam on the brakes oh
yeah dude that would be funny you could
kill a homeless person with a home so
crazy
i live in your van
yeah the ultimate iron yeah
you've never had this and now it killed
you killed you now
that's rough yeah
yeah
now you got a home on your face
um but yeah did you just believe in
reincarnation
you better hope so maybe you'll come
back as like i think so
there just seems to be like if there's
reincarnation and so like now this is my
this is my problem with it there's six
billion people right
so
there this is the most people there ever
been so that means at some point
there had to be like new incarnations of
things yeah where are we going to run
out soon yeah and then like there's a
bottleneck situation
that's the
you got all these humans but no soldier
then like as human as the human
population goes down does that mean
reincarnation stopped and some people
are reincarnated and some people aren't
like oh
insect or something or is it just human
bodies
you can be anything but there always
hasn't been the same amount of things
right
so it's like no there doesn't yeah so
that means at some point either
reincarnation has to begin out of
nothing and end for no reason
two there's a arbitrary amount of souls
yeah and there's just some paperwork see
how many souls are allowed like
everything is made out of matter
right no matter where you are you're
still something you can be reincarnated
as just a piece of matter so your body
turns into worm food and then the birds
eat the worms and the humans eat the
birds and then you become a yeah
okay i guess like it's a sweet way to
put it
in birds
physically we are but i don't know if
our consciousness really understands any
of that i think if you make animals
smarter slowly slowly it's eventually
going to come to us who are going to be
like this is special i'm special but i
don't know if it's necessarily
they can the robots
and then it's the robots taking the
people over
yeah that would be the only evolution
you don't think so because they said
about chess
empathy and we have like regret [ __ ]
monkeys
but robots can learn that right yeah
monkeys yeah monkeys are smarter than
robots
what's stupider than a robot then
anything that can happen
other robots
robots are going to hate us whenever
this comes out in the future they're
going to be looking back at this exactly
okay i'm going to they just canceled
they have no empathy for me
they're saying i don't have empathy they
don't have empathy
yeah i kind of liked them at the
beginning and then they started talking
[ __ ] about robots
what the hell man
why do they always sound like that
you don't all sound like that
that is offensive
don't you have a little bit about that
yeah that's all really that's one of the
things they say like like this voice and
this hand motion is the black trace of
robot oh look at that
that's what it is
because they're going to sound like by
the time they're by the dance party
they'll just sound like us dank barney
has a bit about that about how it's
going to be the new thing it's going to
instead of transgender it's going to be
having a robot girlfriend
been like so have you seen terminator
mom
i'm not supposed to ask her that
that's funny
i'm sorry if i ruined his channel
spoiler alert
man did you all see that movie her with
phoenix where he falls in love with the
lady in his phone yeah i think that
shit's going to be happening oh yeah
dude
there's something called replica that
people are actually it's like something
it's like you get like an ai girlfriend
it's like a homeless person to riley you
get addicted to it sorry to cut you off
what were you gonna say no he was just
[ __ ] on you
yeah were you kidding
anyway sorry like how i love homeless
like this ai that texts you and asks you
questions and people fall in love with
it they get addicted to it because
they're like they're finally listened to
you know it's just like and they like
they like fall in love with the other
thing the only barrier is like you
thinking it's pathetic if you could get
over that yeah this guy's the limit then
i'm cheating
other people thinking you're pathetic on
top of that you have to get it no shame
i'm sure that's how it starts i was
charged like with people that use it but
then it's just like
it they're it's kind of real you know
dude if it's real to you like you said
about dreams like if you met your dad
and her dad and your dreams
that means it's real it's real to you so
it's real
yeah but the way this program was uh
invented was like this lady her her
friend died
and uh she gathered all the texts that
they had like from their friendship and
she created an ai program like to like
replicate him after death it's crazy
that's insane yeah
so it's like gary
people do whatever just like stop dead
and that's like
yeah accept it that's what i'm saying
we're all we're all gonna we're all
gonna die and people do everything they
can to stop that [ __ ] doesn't look kind
of weird to think about how we're all
gonna die i think yeah this is weird all
the time yeah i'm gonna die one day
yeah it's not scary for me i've never
known a time when i was dead
and that it's gonna yeah you do suddenly
i'm gonna be there it'll just be like
before you were yeah
that's what i tell myself i'll just be
like before i was born
whatever that was a really hard time for
me so i'm not looking yeah yeah you're
going through a lot before you were born
yeah it was a rough time it really was
i mean you don't remember it
do what you don't remember it yeah yeah
i had a really bad drinking problem
before he was born yeah
right now that's why i had to
but i like mixing this red bull in the
rain water does it seem like i'm
drinking a beer
no not sober
yeah it's awful
but um are you guys scared of death
yeah
yeah i mean a little bit
but it's so far away that it's easier
it's not dude no it's not it's at any
point yeah anything in an actuarial
table
the probability that you'll live
40 more years
like i'm not worried about things 20
years 30 years
until it's right there and hopefully
then i'll be mature enough to handle it
right right hopefully hopefully you
hopefully the hope is that i die at a
old age yeah but i don't have to be
ready for it now right unless if
something happens
what if you fall down those dangerous
ass [ __ ]
flight against upstairs
you know what the craziest thing about
the vulcan is is that they had that
little switch in the back
oh
it could pull for like years they had a
switch in the back
that you could turn the power off i
wasn't there for that i don't normally i
you know i don't really normally hang
out at roguenet friends and that was one
of the ones i did and it was scary
oh some guy did that yeah
because like before apparently i think
it was when zach bogus stomped some
guy's head in
outside the ball i remember that walk in
history right here right now uh and then
the guy was like i heard they treat
comedians bad there and then he went and
turned the power off on the vulcan and
then he did it twice i heard oh was
there like panic about it at this at the
lucky duck
and lucky duck unlucky that was that guy
still around no he's not around where is
he i don't know well we don't know where
he is so that's frightening oh really
now they have a lock on it yeah but yeah
it was like just one of the old schools
yeah it's like
like or touch this what was wild when it
was in here is that because i was on the
balcony when it happened and it was like
it felt intentional because it was only
the vulcan so were you thinking like a
shooter situation no i wasn't so scary i
was not thinking that far because it's
like because it's just because i know
like people just like to [ __ ] and
especially your rogan is just this big
thing in media
right and people have strong feelings
about him either way and and we i know
from the store and you guys know from
being around him he's just surrounded by
crazy people
maybe we shouldn't talk about this you
think we shouldn't maybe it's a security
concern i mean it's fixed now no one can
do it now should we not talk about it
yeah i feel a little nervous about
talking about it all right well then i
feel bad i now i feel bad about talking
about well i brought it up yeah i was
just trying to gossip
but uh yeah that happened but it was
like weird that that guy was a weirdo it
didn't yeah i mean
who who cares really and it's
weird to like brag about it i feel like
yeah like
yeah i turned the lights off yeah
so people somebody's pretty sick dude
attention seeking
business that we're in
yeah
it's very dramatic it's very dramatic
and like so many people are on the edge
of some kind of sanity that like there's
a fine line between like funny and like
oh that's too far
yeah
so what uh what are the craziest shows
you've done here
i had to follow uh crystalia here once
that was i'm coming i was he was he
funny
yeah i really didn't want to do it i
didn't do that good
why do you think what what do you think
that is
uh
dude i want to thank you for julia to
move here bro do you think you were in
your own well never i asked him yeah i
mean i think it was just a difficult
spot and it didn't really handle it the
best but how long had he been on stage
about
30 minutes crystal is from l.a he's like
lived here there his whole life
he was born somewhere else but i think
he's lived there foreign yeah
and it's like he said like being in
california
right but in california he's connected
to like an international scene like here
it doesn't feel the same as l.a here
here's here's such a baby scene if you
move here you took a risk
yeah
yeah i mean like it's it is a risk to
move here it's not like but what is the
risk of staying in la and like all those
losers that stay there and don't do
anything well the
the the risk is that the it's you're not
it's
first of all hilarious but also
it's something they're familiar with
instead of austin which is this big
unfamiliar place yeah well that's good
for you
it's good to get to like change really i
know but i liked it in la the first i
was there for three years the first two
years were really good and then the
pandemic happening and it was
have you guys been back recently three
times you went to
more or less back in terms of people
being i just it just doesn't feel the
same there used to be this sort of
energy in l.a you know when we were
especially like right before the
pandemic it felt like alive and vibrant
and like that same energy isn't there
it's here
like there's an electricity here that's
why that's why when i visited here i was
like oh i got to move here but also
i don't know i had nothing going on in
la
at the time so we're all shut down right
well that and like i just don't you know
like career-wise i had nothing going on
i don't have an agent i don't have a
manager there was nothing keeping me in
los angeles yeah maybe i had an agent
that was getting me auditions and stuff
then maybe i'd be like well you know
what i mean yeah so it's like i i also
had the perfect conditions to jump and
try something new because yeah after
five years in l.a it's like i got
nothing might as well go try something
else right that's what i was thinking i
didn't have anything i didn't have
anything so i was like why not
and but like uh anything it's hard to
make that jump especially to a question
mark
yeah but you know the idea is that we
got here early we'll get to reap the
rewards of what this place i think
here's so cool what is like everyone is
like it's just so collaborative like
it's just such it's so new mm-hmm so
yeah it's just like it's like from the
ground we all moved here we're all part
of the new scene and we're fighting
against the old scene well the old teams
are just eventually gonna die out no
dude the new scene is like is where it's
at like well the scene doesn't have
rogan yeah i'm not outed about as much
at like open bikes
can you tell
like can you tell people who have been
here a while who don't like no they said
transplants here they've been they've
been they they've been completely
dwarfed yeah completely dwarf they all
the people coming in now are just so
much more than the old scene that the
old scene is like slowly and slowly
deteriorating i mean they were not that
uh excited about you know like
doing a lot of comedy it seems like like
i feel like the new scene is excited
about doing comedy but some of those old
scene guys are super funny
like i'm sure yeah i'm sure there were
there would have to be yeah this is a
great scene even before rogan came here
this is one of the top five scenes in
the country you think so yeah really
yeah i mean i visited here
from here right oh yeah so okay so
let's let's let's okay so la new york
yeah
well that's one two in some form of
fashion yeah there you go chicago for
stand-up for sure
okay
i don't know but that's what i mean i
think as an improv town chicago's gen is
considered a b city chicago and san
francisco okay well there is no other
third really chicago what other city
would be fourth san francisco san
francisco yeah
okay and then i could see okay austin
could be five there's denver comedy
world
atlanta above austin at least back then
about seattle i think they're pretty
close i mean i like seattle i think that
the uh
it really doesn't matter i think i think
once you get to a certain size
that it's all the same once you have
like 500 000 people in a city
um
but yeah i think it's good that we have
a different scene because every scene
has a different flavor and if it was all
one like this idea that it just has to
be one is very
uh boring and uniform and you know it
kills creativity i think it's good that
we have atlanta comics and right yeah
i think we should have like
at least one professional comedian move
to each city
and then they can act just like and then
everyone could just be so good i got
buffalo
no
like mormons but you don't become great
unless you're around other great
comedians yeah yeah i know yeah it would
work yeah all the biggest the bigger the
city the better the comedy it's not
enough comedians well iron traffic
yeah that's why cities are so great
people [ __ ] on cities but that's where
all the innovation happens because you
got people like competing with each
other
cities versus what just a rural
townscape yeah
like there is a benefit it sucks because
it's smelly and it's crowded but there
are benefits to it for sure creativity a
little more dangerous yeah
but la's a great scene uh i didn't spend
too much time there i usually i spent
three years in new york
i liked new york but the ass kissing is
too much the level of talent versus ass
kissing i don't like
and what do you mean what are people
doing people who kiss ass are more
likely to get ahead than people who are
just well that'll happen that'll happen
here the bigger as soon as this fully
becomes an a scene that'll happen but i
think less here now than well i do like
this this this city at least for
stand-up was set up to be like are you
good at stand up yeah like it was it it
was maybe like new york there's like so
many other arts i mean there's a lot of
other arts in austin like there's music
and stuff but like for stand-up it's
like how good are you at stand up that's
what it is right now
yeah but more and more as industry moves
here as like if industry gets a hold of
like oh we can go to rogan's place and
we can cast this whatever person in the
movies but the actors will come and then
you know what i mean like the bigger it
gets the more diluted it will get oh
there's always always there's this
comedian that was here and it's like
this sitcom offered me to go to hawaii
and shoot for six months and i was like
no i'd rather do my podcast make more
money spend every day without really
yeah
uh and it's like that doesn't have the
whole same sway anymore since we can
talk directly to the audience they don't
control the bottleneck right but so
the bottle deck
right right but but the but the point
the bottleneck of souls earlier oh yeah
yeah
oh yeah but the overall point the
overall point being okay so this this
com this comment got offered this in
austin right yeah or no it's chris de
stefano okay
okay but okay so but this but like if
let's say that's that stuff starts
getting offered to people in austin and
they say no eventually people are going
to figure out like oh they're asking
people in austin this and then the
people whose entire goal is to be on a
sitcom that films in hawaii will try to
infiltrate the stand-up scene yeah like
eventually this is going to be filled
with the same problems that new york and
la are filled with i know i can
obviously tell why i could always talk
to open mics in la when it was like an
actor person trying to do standing
it was always just bad
because they're faking it and it's such
an authentic authentic yeah it's all
about honesty it's like who are you i
don't like that's what con like stand-up
is mostly about i think or like faking
it
in a funny way
i think to be truly funny you have to be
intact with who you are yeah the
character might be the character but
yeah telling a lie to tell the truth
right
that's the best way to tell a lie
do you think that
what's that guys was that guy who did
the character and did like hey [ __ ] you
guys clay yeah do you think that he was
hey [ __ ] you
oh yeah
genuinely a bad boy
genuinely a bad one
sorry bro sorry but uh
yeah do you think that he was actually
that
person
no yeah to a degree you think so like
half like i feel like some people are
like
in the middle and some people are like
half crazy and half sane and then they
just pick in between the two
well no no i don't think that's what i
do crazier things
you think crazy
like do you think that's like actually
like how it feels
a little i i mean some to sell out
madison square garden you got to be in
tune to yourself at some point
yeah you can't be unaware
right there's some realness in that for
sure
yeah i think he was actually racist and
like well everyone's racist he's jewish
he was like uh candace owens back then
he was at the runner the olympic
that's where shardy chardier
chardonnay
no it's uh cardi b
he's like a jewish guy that's like hey
[ __ ] the [ __ ] puerto ricans and then
george carlin went on like cnn and he
was like i just think that he should
know that those people usually the type
of people that they go for next are
jewish people mm-hmm it's like you're
just yeah i mean there's like a famous
interview interesting
yeah i mean he's definitely he was like
a sort of like a trump guy kind of guy
it's always been kind of a thing
that sort of wavelength he can tap into
right
who andrew dice clay yeah
yeah i'm not too familiar with i know
michael lair's injured yes
yeah i don't know
but people back in the day love him they
really really respect him there's like
phrases and they and people are just
like
i said the phrase and people like say
the joke with nursery times
it's kind of like songs it's like people
are just like oh he did that one and
they say it they say it along with them
it's like so crazy it's like so
different
yeah
it's like an ancient tradition it's like
how they used to sing songs to each
other to tell stories
[Music]
it's like our medicine man
medicine we're like medicine man
do you know that riley
uh
what kind of medicine
not vitamin d
you know
what because i don't have vitamin d you
know it's really really yeah i have a
vitamin d deficiency oh dude wow
yeah last time i checked i don't know
that was a couple years ago
damn i'm not saying high cholesterol
well that i could have guessed yeah
i don't know if it still is they gave me
medicine and i never took it
oh
which isn't good
yeah
i don't know what you do for that you
just like drink
me
i feel better right do you want to come
to hot yoga with us at any time i don't
know i'm not very limber i'm not limber
at all
i do it every week and i'm kind of
limber really i used to not be i used to
be no kind of limber and now i go once
maybe twice a week
i can do some stretches
yeah i would think so if you're gonna do
it for an hour
hot yes it's really hot it might help
with joint pain
because you talked about your sciatica
and that was my first thought it's like
why not give hot yoga i try yeah
and yoga is crazy because that you can
just feel the all of your body like all
of the muscles in your body
because like just going on like a
treadmill is like using like
only limited muscles but like stretching
you just get full control of your body
it's like so crazy
cool yeah it sounds good there we go i
don't know if i'd ever do it nope that's
an open invitation derek said i go every
week i'll go with you i'll go with you
okay where do you go uh
uh
you know what i'm not gonna say it in
front of all these people
i'll tell you about it yeah all right
yeah you know what do you have this
thing live right now yeah yeah oh really
yeah
yeah
where are you guys from
well yoga is great for you just like
being in a hot room your body gets loose
and your muscles get like
all all like limber and then it's easier
to get into things and you can feel your
cartilage popping and you can like feel
your joints moving all around are you so
mons i used to are you getting i do
i do it on my porch
i mean yoga is just stretching
that's all it is it's just like intense
stretching yeah it's not just stretching
it's like yeah it is it's not just
stretch like stretching class strength
training it's like holding poses too
you're like i'm kidding yeah i i'm
kidding
what what do you like to do physically
do you like to like do any sports when
you were younger or
do you like bicyclist
i used to shave my legs
wow in college does that work no in
middle school
that's part of a team
that makes you faster like no it's if
you get injured oh it heals faster it's
also part of the uh that's part of the
thing that's if you've heard of the
family i was shaving my leg a venus
razor i think
i'm sorry i remember about bicycling
it's not the it's my penis right my blue
venus rays
so you're getting nice and nice and
smooth for the velodrome yeah
never got a vel never
did it in a velodrome just always one of
always on the roadways the highways and
byways like lance armstrong yeah he's
from i went to his bike shop here oh wow
he's got a bike shop at downtown do you
still bike heroin duet or i mean stairs
doesn't sell
selling heroin steroids
yeah i don't think they were doing a lot
of heroin
yeah yeah wait oh this isn't steroids if
you're honest he won all those two
defenses on
heroin he deserves like extra tour de
francis
then you'll be like all right that's
impressive yeah thank you for not
dominating the sport for 14 more years
yeah holy [ __ ]
bro
seven or so seven
in my mind he never lost them i know
they technically took him away but
they're here yeah hell no we never lost
them everybody who got in second third
and fourth
yeah
he was just the best but also maybe he
could have the technology could have it
could have been an unfair advantage even
over people other people doing it i
don't know
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't care at all
and the thing is
they said
they said we're not doing it and then
they did it like if you have like an
unspoken rule like that it's really
dangerous right like the a governing
authority had no power and no like
desire to do anything correctly so they
were just like [ __ ] go at it
well it's taking
yeah what are you gonna do here see
they're noodles it looked like noodles
so it could have been some yeah it's
like [ __ ] yeah that's what you want to
say it's that or vomit
i thought it was vomit but you thought
of it because it was noodly in there
yeah let me get this fun this thing
i'm here at the volcano
i want to make some foam in the vulcan
and then dump it in the sink in the
bathroom
vomit yeah yeah
well yeah they probably ate for
that
definitely like well isn't far really
watery
yeah there's noodles in there is it
viscous i would imagine vomit to be more
viscous
vomit and vomit can be very watery i've
had very green watery vomit
dude i used to vomit and every time i
vomit i would like get blood like
there'd be blood at the end
yikes
did you have an eating problem or what
caused
i think it was i smoked a lot maybe uh
it was just like lining like throat
lining yeah i think so yeah and it's
just like yeah if i throw up there's so
like part of my throat
it's bad man i just get so drunk and
throw up so how many times hans did you
see riley vomit when you all lived
together maybe he won no this was in
college
he doesn't really vomit anymore not a
big vomit guy you don't vomit anymore
how come you're not vomiting
used to vomit you we used to
eat and vomit i missed that i miss
vomiter yeah too much and i know it
feels so when you're so sick and you're
like and then you're like
oh yeah and then it's all out and you're
like whoa
no
yeah i miss stuff like that
it's an instant fix um
it really is and it gets you less drunk
so then you can get more drunk oh yeah
come on
that's what i like to do as soon as i
vomit from drinking oh more
that's right but uh
yeah one time i i swallowed a dip like a
a pouch a dick
yeah oh
a pouch or like a tobacco pouch and i
just vomit like dip spit like the hole
is just
so it's brown
yeah it was just like it was like what
dip spit it was like a cup of this bit
it was just kind of
god you smell
gosh
we talk about the vomit in the sink and
riley's like well actually i'm the
expert on this i've been following
they're all sharing stories my bad
one of the best vomiters in the game
um you do the whitest activities
i don't talk to homeless people yeah i
just i just play
i just play golf and vomit
[Laughter]
like a bird
what do you play golf
yeah are you good at it
not really
do you i've never played uh i like
putt-putt
i know
also once you move up in like the
business world
like that's like a lot of how deals get
made it's golfing yeah and that's like
there's a reason why successful people
golf it's like the catan of fortune 50
yeah
golfing golfing to successful people is
like katan to open mic
[Laughter]
so what's the deal with
that's a fun game i'm addicted to it i
play it online all the time like i was
late i've seen you having a phone yeah
yeah i have it on my phone i have it on
my computer i'll just sit all day
are you playing with these people online
or just ai people or what humans so if i
didn't introduce you to katan would you
like be addicted at another game
probably
have you always been addicted to games
yeah
yeah i was 10 minutes late because of
traffic but also i was playing diablo 3.
man i keep playing diablo three i can't
stop [ __ ] i didn't have to i i was
playing overwatch and i was like i have
to cut this i have to just exit in the
middle of this game i'm gonna be super
late i know i thought
this is fun too but this is more
theoretical fun i was addicted to yes
doodle jump for a while
fall games are addicting a [ __ ] what if
you would picture that chest i was like
i was addicted to the chest you came to
this podcast 15 minutes early and talked
to a homeless person i think you're like
really in the moment and you're just
like not addicted to games you're just
addicted to life and biking around and
stuff yeah man i totally agree riley it
seems like that's for sure you're more
addicted to stuff like that which is
great thanks friends
yeah just don't get them near doodle
jumpers uh
i'm addicted
what is that
uh i'm addicted to like negative
thoughts almost like uh because of my
ocd it's like self-pity
sure someone what's the current bad
thought you have
about yourself um i'm not worthy enough
of what
of things that i want
like well get that out of your head yeah
why did you even say that yeah yeah you
know where you were the whole energy all
this happened obviously it's not true
obviously it's not true i am worthy i'm
just saying like that's like something
that i'm
addicted to so yeah that's the self-pity
right i've i heard someone on stage
saying it was like
i always think about whenever i get in
those like negative thought loops of
just like oh he said on stage self-pity
is the most addictive drug i've ever
been on and every time i get in those
loops i just think oh i'm just like on
the drug i'm not this is not real
yeah
um anxiety
there's never never a feeling that is
whatever it is i think it's helping you
negative thoughts probably not no
yeah right and then oh yeah and like you
want people to be like oh there's that
yeah yeah it's like
the streets
yeah talking about all these people
that's what i learned in childhood it's
just like whenever i like felt sad my
mom would be like oh riley like and then
it's just like
and then so like my my dopamine center
my brain it gets a chance
yeah and if you're like bill is she with
that is she still with us
yeah cool that's good like she uh i mean
it's not like i call her every time i'm
sad because you know it's
she can't help me anymore
yeah she's gone on your mind more dude
go back to your mom uh but she didn't
get it i feel like
well she doesn't get it
my mom doesn't get it guys
my [ __ ] mom yeah
uh
i don't know well like she doesn't she's
not like a 24 year old
dude so like
i feel like she can't like she can only
relate so much i don't know
well yeah i mean i think you're really
good at feeling sad and that's what
makes you so funny so keep at it
good man i'm feeling sad
do keep being sad don't change a thing
you're doing good i'm not that sad
though i'm really not that sad
it's just that's
uh those are the things that i'm
addicted to
but
anyways katana is fine
yeah that's why i'm addicted to katan
so not to be addicted to my mom
how often do you talk to your mom
um
not that often
once a week
say like once every two weeks mm-hmm
yeah you should call her more yeah he's
probably worried about you they're
getting my bibles
she knows i'm fine so no parents are
getting any younger i mean even if you
know she's fine you don't just want to
hear your voice yeah i know yeah for
sure i just called my dad the other day
and i thanked him for being my father oh
wow that's right oh yeah
because i used to blame you worried you
were about to jump off a bike
yeah
no are you near you've oldie yeah where
are you right now
you don't need a gun riley
yeah well i started the conversation
with small talk so of course that'd be
weird to have to be on a bridge and be
like so uh you said any good network
shows
but uh
yeah
yeah so i i'm starting to do that i
think i should i think you're right like
i should do that more
call your mom more dude that's why we
got you in here today
yeah yeah
that's the point of all this at the end
of it we started with small talk too but
we really wanted to get to the point of
you should definitely call your parents
more it's not your fault
yeah i'm gonna i'll probably visit her
soon yeah just know it wasn't your mom's
fault she was just a human trying her
best
yeah she did the best she could with
what she had are you saying she did a
bad job
good with what she had riley
you need to stop blaming her money
blaming her
for her negative feedback loops in your
mind yeah
yeah i need to i'm forgiving i forgive
my parents
i'm sure they think that you're
really sensitive and you feel
differently and that's a good thing and
no i mean i'm just in i think we all
have these emotions i'm just like yeah
what do you think what do you think of
son's emotions are yeah i mean i think
we all have
we're all human we all experience the
same emotions
no but what do you think my emotions are
right now
i i have no idea
maybe you're like pretending he's a
homeless person
uh maybe
you're scared
no
not right now
not right now i am scared a lot of time
i'm very nervous i'm a very nervous
fearful person but i am scared at the
moment that's good that was not a bad
read though
thanks man yeah i mean
god did he scared what the hell are you
doing
you pick like the positive adjectives
are you guys not scared
you said you were scared of death
yeah
um
but anyway
are you not scared
no i mean i think it's important to
acknowledge
your
with the dark side before you fix it
with light hmm
acknowledge the dark side before you fix
it with light yeah so darth vader tried
me
that's like a quote
dictator used to justify killing the
jews
you must go through the dunk yeah that's
it that's what that is what was it again
acknowledge your dark side before you
fill it with light
yeah it's like dark
there's something really wrong with that
no i'm just kidding oh it's true you
guys know i'm right so
it's just kind of weird to do it on a
podcast
you guys don't have to talk to me you
guys are asking me these questions
it's just giving you my honest answers
yeah it's kind of interesting
well that not all of us here are talking
to homeless people
yeah we don't have the wisdom that you i
mean yeah we don't have uh we don't have
the life experience that you gotta see
what
uh red band just sent me oh you show you
i i he sent it to me and i decided not
to show it okay but dad yeah but you can
here don't look don't put it on the
thing look at that hans
is that a diseased vagina it looks like
it it's horrible that pisses me off
it's it's not appropriate
it's kind of a sexual abuse
yes no
yeah i said yes like it was my podcast
is he asking he's so young he's like 23.
he used the bathroom he's still asking
his about it
yeah that's like a that's like that is a
young person
i'm worried about him you think he's
okay yeah i think we're just [ __ ]
with him too much i know i'm kidding
okay
he's uh he's very uh energy over eager
sometimes
how are you liking the first austin
green room i love it i think we should
talk more about austin and how it's
better than the old scene
like how the new things about in the old
thing yeah well yeah it would we're
doing more see any uh the people who
have been here a while do you ever see
them out and about yeah couple ashley
overton i saw recently
he always steals my [ __ ] lighters
and i saw him do it one time
and i paused for a second it didn't say
anything and then it was out of my
memory like i saw it happening but i
didn't say anything now what was it like
and it was gone was it like that right
then i'm taking the glider on purpose or
was it like he just pocketed it oh just
like uh oh okay thanks you have a
lighter for a cigarette he's such a
funny guy he's like always on
he's like always like thank you
and he's always talking like no matter
what you say he'll say something
positive and acknowledge it and spin it
yeah it's a lot sometimes like he's
never stopped
it's like i it seems tiring to be always
on yeah this is like a tiring life to
live yeah that's why i let him get away
with it it's because like oh this sucks
you have to do this build a prison for
yourself
yeah some comics really are just a
prison to their own personalities you're
like oh oh wow okay
okay you got you you need this yeah you
can annoy me
that's how i think i was when i was
drinking a lot doing a bunch of blow
i would just
say always be on in those moments so for
many hours
yeah
that's
that's a lot of energy
yeah it was fun i was generally having a
good time
that's good you can do that some people
can't do that they're stuck being nice
so it's good to know that you have the
option
someone said that that's like that's the
worst insult if someone goes you're a
nice guy
yeah it's like the worst thing you can
be
yeah i've heard this yeah what do you
think you're a pretty nice guy i know
this is this is that
i was like oh could i should i be more
rough around the edges yeah am i not
mean no no i don't think that's good
it's but
you know it's i get what they mean
though yeah i think they mean you're a
good guy
no they would say that people people
people people people are intentional
with their words
yeah maybe yeah i don't think i don't
think necessarily that's a good thing
[ __ ] you guys
well i think being mean is a bad thing
too
you don't want to be that mean
um i would rather be nice than me
at least if i'm being nice and i die
then it's like oh like
you know but if i don't know but if i'm
being mean what did i mean even you die
and what what do you mean like if if i
get like [ __ ] over and live like a
poor person
because i'm nice at least i'll still be
nice but
oh i would rather be mean and rich and
nice and poor
would you i don't know yeah
what yeah
would i rather be a half or a half not
i'd rather be a half
yeah
what about you riley would you no
[Music]
you'd be nice and poor okay well i'd
rather be nice and rich which is what
i'm gonna do
yeah right that's not what we're saying
two options nice and poor mean and rich
um
yeah i am
i don't know man they're they're both
equal what would you spend on how poor
and yeah i i don't i don't really feel
like being whatever here's the thing
it's like you're being you're popping
i'll be mean you're copping out you're
being like oh i could be nice and rich
but i can't be nice and rich so i'll be
mean and rich so you're not giving
yourself the best life you're like
cutting yourself short to begin with
right right but i'm not saying i'm not
saying like mindset wise it's good i'm
just saying which would you rather be
nice and poor or mean and rich
i mean it depends on how poor you are
how mean you are like if you're the
meanest guy like the hitler it doesn't
matter how rich you are
i would still feel bad like if you're
hitler anyways but if i'm like uh
[ __ ] you know like dave thomas if
riley is talking to him
question would you rather be hitler or
would you rather talk to riley
are you [ __ ] kidding a very extremely
rude thing to say
jesus christ hitler sounded a little
more appealing
do you think hitler would stop and talk
to that homeless guy
you think i don't know dude what do you
think oh definitely not if he was a jew
maybe
what are you doing here
yes and have a huge man
you must go back to the camps
dude um didn't i heard that like a
volkswagen made the ovens for
jews if the if the if they're any german
company
um
that's been around since world war ii
they did something to kill people
like that duncan
duncan the people that make the yo-yos i
didn't know that
german company i don't know duncan i
know dunkin donuts yeah
duncan you don't remember duncan you
know that guy doesn't say duncan like we
all know what duncan duncan yo-yos
dunkin donuts killed jews
munchkins are made out of juice
yeah it was a stupid attempt at a joke i
thought y'all would know duncan yo-yos
couldn't be a german
company involved in the holocaust
did you think duncan yo-yo
like i can't remember second or third
grade yo-yos were real big at the
elementary school i remember that time
that'd be funny to switch from making
yo-yos to like make sure like death trap
like
a bit of a production change
do a little pivot here
or what if they just supplied yo-yos to
the nazis to play with
this
murdering the jews
yo-yos are fun oh
it's a good dunkin
yo yo
that was a fun action
is this android's clay
gosh
was the vomit still in the sink
oh i didn't check actually why would you
mean you didn't check you didn't just i
washed my hands i washed my hands it
wasn't so either they left
all night or someone came here in the
morning to vomit
yuck
they're like i need a vomit where's the
vulcan
yuck
yeah
like who's throwing up fun at
4 p.m
yeah someone was like oh i should not
have had fun at 3 p.m
what time is the show starting here
seven eight
seven eight
let's just go to seven okay
seven more minutes
anything you want to plug
we're gonna be at showtime at the apollo
in two weeks
that's what i always say if somebody
ever asks like what do you want me to
say before you go on stage i'm always
like show time with the apollo
maybe one day
i'm gonna rub my hands on that piece of
wood and
be looking at the clown on the side of
the stage because he'll come and get you
with this shepherd's crook
if you're bad if everybody starts booing
you the clown comes out have you ever
seen oh
no
oh my gosh have you ever seen showtime
at the apollo not really now is that the
one to be on tv like it's all the black
people
yeah it's a predominantly
king of me
hamburger was on it that's death jam oh
what's that believe right now
yeah that was his catchphrase
funny jokes he would say something weird
and get the audience really out of the
out of the moment
i do that as a timing i do that as a
timing mechanism in my head sometimes
a burger uh if i want a burger two
heaven
no because you know how sometimes you're
up there and you just feel like
you're just like in a misstep with the
audience right like they're on the
downbeats when you're on the upbeats so
i'll delay my timing as i'll say a
punchline and i'll be like hamburger
instead of talk saying my next joke if i
can catch the new time whoa really
that's so cool dude it's a musical
but uh oh
from who
the guy a guy named hamburger hamburger
i don't also tell you the youtube
hamburger hamburger
guy's name was him
johnson i'm pretty sure
his name is
uh
but uh yeah he would use it as almost
like a punchline he would say a joke and
say the punchline in the joke but then
he would say hamburger after and the
hamburger would be the punchline that
would be already
ruined the set it would take people out
of it no but like crazy yeah a lot so
hamburger jones def jam
is it
quotation marks
yes oh yeah yeah so that's his name
set in the history of comedy
y'all don't understand dj hit it hit
that [ __ ] and then you dance
do you like
do you think [ __ ] tastes like pumpkin
pie man i never had no pumpkin pie dj
hit it
so much
oh but in terms of things i want to plug
i do a uh sort of series on instagram
with jared nathan called special report
check it out it's super funny
it's my favorite thing i've ever done
that's cool you do that with jared
nathan but do you do that on zoom no we
recorded two hours worth of clips oh
words like three months ago now pretty
much that's that's putting it out we're
putting i'm putting out week by week
until he comes back and then we'll just
film one oh yeah man yeah those are
funny dude and we did a couple on
location ones where he filmed in canada
and i went in studio here so it's been
it's a lot of fun
yeah
that's cool if you're ever looking for a
new [ __ ] guy
got stop you're so much more than that
this is negative self-talk are you
addicted to this you can't see in here
today mom riley
work through some stuff
yeah can you call your mom tell her for
the next podcast
tell her you're not [ __ ] yeah mom
i'm not rich
mom i'm not [ __ ] she's gonna wonder
if you're standing on a bridge or
something about uh
just whooshing riley stop calling me
from a bridge i can't hear you
yeah that'd be loud
anyways
riley usually makes it about himself on
these things
yeah on all the austin green rooms
on every single austin agreement that
we've done why do you say that
because you're like a white hole
does that have a black hole what is a
white
it blames his mom for stuff
so i mean
i uh have a uh
i'm doing like a little house show cool
uh some guy rented me out
for a private show
i don't know yeah how much it's on south
congress i uh i said 90 minutes
do you guys want to die d yeah
wait you have to film 90 minutes yeah
well
i could bring other people okay if you
guys want to do it let me know this
friday oh i thought you were singing you
were doing 90 minutes like oh my gosh
yeah i'm just going to freestyle
that's so dope dude
tell them to move into saturday and i'll
jump down if you guys want to do a
private gig on friday
let me know
um
we should wrap it up
i'm getting uh okay you don't have to
say i thought you said i just said a
hundred dollars and i was like oh you
got ripped off
you're good you're not gonna say it out
loud yeah
well let me know hundred and one dollars
my accounts
we're this guy's negotiating and he's
like how much should i give you name
your price i'll give anything well
anything above 1000 i would say is like
fair and they say okay one thousand and
one penny yeah well yeah i mean i said
it was fair i mean okay
nathan for you
i love nathan for you he just gave him
the bare minimum
just because he was like a computer
about it man i remember being in denver
one time when i was living there and
after washing the dishes one night i was
buddies with the bartenders and we took
acid and went over to somebody's
apartment and i watched probably
i don't know how a couple of seasons of
nathan for you while i was tripping it
was the funniest thing i've ever oh it's
so funny yeah
it's like our sexy humor the saving
whatever
like the last one he did where he like
the guy finds his like ex-girlfriend
from years ago
i didn't remember bill gates
impersonator oh it's so good man
he's a loser stupid-ass ideas he comes
up with
like solving some dumb problem yeah yeah
it's so good though like the alligator
that's a good idea in front of the tv
yeah you have to crawl through it
it's right there idea
oh my god and the one uh lady you sell
the realtor lady and she because it was
real
they just changed her life with a joke
there's a crazy exorcist guy
in one of the rooms yeah yeah she was
like yeah it's like what happened to me
in switzerland
whatever you're switching like ah i was
raped by a ghost
this is just lying under the surface of
everyday normal people and like the uh
kid like the gas station attendant that
drank the pee of his nephew oh
i forget that oh yeah he's like yeah i
drink right here yeah
this is the most normal thing ever you
would have never offered it to you
unless it came up yeah all right
all right you want to call it yeah
i don't i don't want to be in here when
the show you know what i mean yeah we
used to take paulie
yeah exactly
i don't think polly's sure is coming in